crayon crayon crayon crayon prin crane
mmm
she's a crayon crayon crayon friend
crayon no you know it's one syllable
there was Granick huge debate about this
in college but like ah
Kenny's confusing College in
kindergarten because he says crane
Carmel
I don't know how expecting that caramel
caramel caramel caramel wait did you say
caramel no I say caramel caramel see but
I sometimes say caramel and sometimes
they say caramel it really depends
really
I never say caramel it's like caramel
that's too fancy Who am I some
highfalutin cutting character jewelry
jewelry jewelry yeah jewelry awesome it
was a jewelry
oh they're overachievers to worry mm-hmm
do you know no one says you will read
jewelry jewelry this is another like you
know you gotta take the time to enjoy
the syllables in the words if you try to
rob someone and we're like give me your
jewelry I would just laugh hero hero you
know gyro
hero hero whoa
I would say gyro Leto which is the way
the Greek people say it I think it could
be Giro it could be guy rub gyro he says
Gary it makes me feel like it dirty and
I say gyro it's a Greek word so I'm
gonna just give us points for no nobody
should speak is what we've learned this
is why texting is the new evolution of
language I just I feel like you can't
apply logic to the English language
[Laughter]
[Music]